First of all,
you unite your mind,
you're thinking,
let's say with your emotions.
So that makes one thing instead of two fighting things.
Okay,
that's a good one.
And then the next conjunction he talked about was it isn't enough to unite your
mind and your emotions.
And he thought about that as a male female pairing symbolically.
That's how it would manifest itself sometimes in dreams.
So you take the masculine element and the feminine element,
the the thinking and the emotion unite those.
And that makes you more like one thing.
Okay.
And now all of a sudden that's represented as symbolically mail.
That one thing and it unites with something else that's now represented
symbolically,
seven female,
that's the body.
So you take the mind,
emotion integration and integrate that in your body.
So what does that mean?
You act it out instead of just thinking.
So there's this philosophical idea called a,
now I'm going to forget what it's called.
It's a contradiction in action.
There's actually a technical term for it,
but that's when you think and believe something,
but you're,
but you don't act it out.
And so that means there is a dissociation in you somehow between your abstract
representations and what you manifest in action.
While that's another form of discontinuity that isn't doing you any good.
You know the driver's going one way and the cars going the other and you won't
even be able to understand yourself if you do that.
But even more,
you're not putting your principles into practice so you're disassociated.
You're being is dissociated.
So once you get your mind and your emotions working together,
then the next thing to do is to act that out consistently.
So that was the second conjunction as far as young was concerned.
And then the third one was,
this is the tough one and this is the one that's related to phenomenology.
You erase the distinction between yourself and the world.
Okay,
that's a tough one.
So imagine you're dealing with someone who's hoarding.
Now,
people who are hoarding are often older or neurologically damaged or they have
obsessive compulsive disorder.
But then you walk into their house and there's like 10,000 things in their
house.
There's,
there's,
there's maybe a hundred boxes and you open up a box and in the box there's some
pens and some old passports and some checks and their collection of silver
dollars and some hypodermic needles and some Dustin,
you know,
a dead mouse and,
and,
and there's boxes and boxes and boxes is like that in the house.
It's absolute chaos in their absolute chaos,
not ordered chaos.
And then you think is that their houses that they're being,
is that their mind and answer is there's no difference.
There's no difference.
So,
you know,
I could say,
well,
if you want to organize your psyche,
you could start by organizing your room if they've thought would be easier
because maybe you're a more concrete person and you need something concrete to
do.
So you go clean up under your bed and you make your bed and you organize the
papers on your desk and you think,
well,
just exactly what are you organizing?
Are you organizing the objective world or are you objecting your field?
Are you organizing your field of being like your field of total experience?
And young believed that.
And I think that there's a Buddhist doctrine that sort of nested in there that
at the highest level of psychological integration,
there's no difference between you and what you experience.
Now you think,
well,
I can't control everything I experienced,
but that's no objection because you can't control yourself anyway.
So the mere fact that you can't extend control over everything you experience is
no argument against the idea that you should still treat that as an extension of
yourself.
So you can say,
well,
let's say you have a long standing feud with your brother while sat a
psychological problem.
Is that him?
Is it a problem in the objective world?
Or is,
is it a problem in your field of being?
And it's very useful to think that way because you might ask,
what could you do to improve yourself?
Well,
let's step one step backwards.
The first question might be,
why should you even bother improving yourself?
And I think the answer to that is something like,
so you don't suffer any more stupidly than you have to.
And maybe so others don't have to either.
It's something like that,
you know,
like there's a real injunction at the bottom of it.
It's not some casual self-help doctrine.
It's that if you don't organize yourself properly,
you'll pay for it and in a big way.
And so will the people around you now and you could say,
well I don't care about that,
but that's actually not true.
You actually do care about that because if you're in pain,
you will care about it.
And so you do care about it.
Even if it's just that negative way,
you know,
it's very rare that you can find someone who's in excruciating pain who would
ever say,
well,
it would be no better if I was out of this sort of pain is one of those things
that brings the idea that it would be better if it didn't exist along with it.
It's in controvertible so you get your act together so that there isn't any more
stupid pain around you than necessary.
We'll,
so then the question might be,
well how would you go about getting your act together?
And the answer to that.
And this is a phenomenological idea too,
it's something like look around for something that bothers you and see if you
can fix it.
So now you think,
well let's say there,
let's say you go into,
you can do this in a room.
It's quite fun to do it just when you're sitting in a room like a room,
maybe your bedroom,
you can sit there and just sort of meditate on it and think,
okay,
if I wanted to spend 10 minutes making this room better,
what would I have to do?
And you have to ask yourself that,
right?
It's not a command.
It's like our genuine question and things will pop out in the room that you know
you like there's a stack of papers over there that's kind of bugging you and you
know that maybe little order there would be a good thing and you know,
you haven't,
there's some rubbish behind your computer monitor that you haven't attended to
for like six months.
And the room would be slightly better if it was a little less dusty and the
cables weren't all tangled up the same way.
And like if you,
if you allow yourself just to consider the expanse in which you exist at that
moment,
there'll be all sorts of things that'll pop out in it that you could just fix.
And you know,
I might say,
well,
if you were coming to see me for psychotherapy,
this smell,
easiest thing for us to do first would just be to get you to organize your room.
You think,
well,
is that psychotherapy?
And the answer is,
well,
it depends on how you conceive the limits of your being.
And I would say start where you can start.
You know,
if,
if something announces itself to you,
which is a strange way of thinking about it,
as in need of repair that you could repair,
then hey,
fix it.
You fix a hundred things like that.
Your life will be a lot different.
Now,
I often tell people to fix the things you repeat every day because people tend
to think of those as trivial,
right?
You get up,
you brush your teeth,
you have your breakfast,
you know,
you have your routines that you go through every day.
Well though,
those probably constitute 50% of your life.
And people think,
well,
they're mundane,
I don't need to pay attention to them.
It's like,
no,
that's exactly wrong.
The things you do every day,
those are the most important things you do hands down.
All you have to do is do the arithmetic.
You figure it out right away.
So a hundred adjustments to your broader domain of being and there's a lot less
rubbish and there's a lot less rubbish around it,
a lot fewer traps for you to step into.
And so that's in keeping with Ewing's idea about erasing the dis.
Once you've got your mind and your emotions together,
and once you're acting that out,
then you can extend what you're willing to consider yourself and start fixing up
the things that are part of your broader extent.
Now sometimes you don't know how to do that.
So you might say,
imagine you're walking down Bloor street and there's this guy who's like
alcoholic and schizophrenia and has been on the streets for 10 years.
He sorta stumbled towards you and you know,
incoherently mutters something.
That's a problem.
And it would be good if you could fix it,
but you haven't got a clue about how to fix that.
You just walk around that and go find something that you could fix.
Because if you muck about in that,
not only is it unlikely that you'll help that person,
it's very likely that you'll get hurt yourself.
So you know,
just because while you're experiencing things,
announced themselves as in need of repair,
doesn't mean that it's you right that in there that should repair them.
You have to have some humility.
You know,
you don't walk up to a helicopter that isn't working and just start tinkering
away with it.
You,
you have to stay within your domain of competence.
But most of the time,
if people look at their lives,
you know,
it's very interesting thing to do.
I liked the,
I liked the idea of the room because you can do that at the drop of a hat.
You know,
we'd go back to where you live and sit down and think,
okay,
I'm gonna make this place better for half an hour.
What should I do?
It you have to ask.
And things will just pop up like mad.
And it's partly because your mind is a very strange thing.
As soon as you give it a name,
a genuine aim,
it'll reconfigure the world in keeping with that aim,
that that's actually how you see to begin with.
And so if you said it a task,
especially if you have to be genuine about it,
which is why you have to bring your thoughts and emotions together,
and then you have to get them into your body.
So you're acting consistently,
you have to be genuine about the aim.
But once you aim,
the world will reconfigure itself around that aim,
which is very strange.
And,
and it's,
it's,
it's technically true.